House Republicans yesterday voted to
overturn two bills that had been passed
by the D.C Council that would allow
non-citizens to vote in local elections
and go even softer on criminals
and Congress lady Alexandria
ocasio-cortez she is not happy about it
in direct contradiction of their
quote-unquote conservative values of
small government and defending Freedom
have decided to expand the jurisdiction
of this body to meddle into the the
business of D.C residents the D.C city
council has the right to determine its
policies for D.C residents and if any
member of this body does not like that
they are feel they can feel free to
change their registration resign their
post and run for D.C City Council
now AOC says lots of things that are not
true but very often the false things
that she says are false because they are
exaggerations or selective
interpretations or imaginative
predictions in this case though what AOC
said is just perfectly precisely
easily demonstrably wrong the D.C city
council does not have the right to
determine the policies for D.C residents
Congress does have that right and that
right doesn't come from some obscure
section of the U.S code or some
little-known Court decision it is laid
out explicitly in the Constitution
Article 1 Section 8 quote the Congress
shall have the power to exercise
exclusive legislation in all cases
whatsoever over the Federal District of
Washington D.C now at first I figured
AOC was just being disingenuous
the more I listen to her rant though the
more convinced I became that she just
sincerely doesn't have any idea how the
Constitution established the government
of D.C
I understand that there may be
disagreement I understand that uh that
that Republicans may not be happy with
what the D.C city council is doing but
when cities in Vermont pass the same
Provisions when San Francisco when nine
Maryland cities brought up this
provision did the Republican Party
Corral all of Congress and bring this
issue down to the floor for a vote no
they did not they are singling out the
residents of the District of Columbia
and expanding in the history of
disenfranchisement that goes all the way
back to the legacy of slavery and
they're bringing it right here to this
floor because why they don't have any
real bills to debate
no it's just because that's congress's
job
the Congress is not overruling laws in
Vermont and Maryland and in San
Francisco because that's not congress's
responsibility
it's just basic Civics the sort of thing
you're supposed to learn by the fifth
grade especially in a republic which
cannot endure if even the elected
representatives don't understand the
basic functions of the government I'm
Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show
foreign
[Music]
back to the show my favorite comment
yesterday is from Vince Dao who says
that was me in the suit on the panel
about assimilation Erasure and crime
very cool thank you Michael I'm pleased
to hear it that's great it's kind of
funny to play a clip on the show and
then have the person in the clip say oh
I was watching you talk about that thing
that's great uh well Vince you did a
great job this was in the clip yesterday
on my show from Vice this great Vice
documentary where they're talking about
all sorts of woke nonsense and you've
got this one conservative guy and then
all the libs around him who were just
absolutely aghast whenever he says
anything even remotely commonsensical
like like really basic stuff I thought
you did a great job it's terrific and we
got to talk at some point not just
through this show maybe we'll talk on
the phone when you want to talk to your
friends on the phone you got to check
out pure talk right now go to
puretalk.com use promo code Knowles Pure
Talk is the antidote to woke wireless
companies it is proudly veteran owned
employs a us-based customer service team
and absolutely refuses to spend money on
fake news networks not to mention Pure
Talk service is fantastic they are one
of the largest networks in the country
you can get blazing fats data talk and
text for as low as 30 dollars per month
that is probably half or less than half
of what you are currently paying Verizon
ATT T-Mobile switch over to Pure Talk in
as little as 10 minutes while keeping
your phone in your phone number your
first month is guaranteed risk-free try
it and if you are not completely happy
with the service you will get your money
back stop throwing money out the window
you will get the same great Network you
will get better customer service you can
switch in a very short amount of time do
it today make it a goal to support
companies that support you go to
puretalk.com enter promo code Knowles
you'll save 50 on your first month
puretalk.com promo code Knowles Pure
Talk is simply smarter Wireless
I don't usually go after AOC these days
I don't hit her so much anymore because
I feel it's played out I feel this is
the most basic superficial kind of
conservative commentary these days is
just
hey you see how crazy AOC is you could
do that you could fill a show with that
every single day and so I generally stay
away from it but sometimes
sometimes AOC
demonstrates such blithe ignorance that
one cannot ignore it
and this occurred not just yesterday
talking about Washington DC not knowing
what the government of Washington DC is
supposed to be even according to the
Constitution but this happened a couple
days ago too when AOC was discussing the
big Tech
hearings and testimony when when the
Congress was grilling these big Tech
Executives especially on things like the
hunter Biden laptop story AOC went on a
tangent about how upset she is that Libs
of tick tock one of the great Twitter
accounts is still on Twitter despite
spreading false information
Miss navaroli are you familiar with the
account Libs of tick tock
I have heard of it from the news yes
um Mr Roth are you familiar with this
account
yes ma'am I am
are you aware from that from August 11
to August 16th that account posted false
information about Boston Children's
Hospital claiming that they were
providing hysterectomies
to Children okay
the claim the accusation Libs of tick
tock posted false information
suggesting that the Boston Children's
Hospital
transes the kids specifically provides
hysterectomies to children that's the
claim let's check to see if that
claim holds up Boston Children's
Hospital take it away
some gender affirming hysterectomies
will also include the removal of the
ovaries but that's technically a
separate procedure called bilateral
oophorectomy and not every
gender-firming hysterectomy includes
that and people who are getting gender
from hysterectomies do not have to have
their ovaries removed
so it sounds like limbs of tick tock was
right
because I'm watching a commercial now
from Boston Children's Hospital talking
about performing these hysterectomies I
I guess you could say that Libs of tick
tock didn't go far enough
because Libs of tick tock should also
maybe have talked about bilateral
euphrectomies
is that how you pronounce that but
they did it AOC could have just Googled
that AOC launches into this this long
emotional rant about how Libs of tick
tock is lying about Boston Children's
Hospital and hysterectomy she could have
just Googled it it would have taken like
five words
she didn't do that
she could have saved herself the rant
about Washington DC by reading the
Constitution even just one time or
Having learned anything in civics class
in elementary school and I know that
they were teaching Civics back when ioc
was in school in Westchester because I
grew up one town away from AOC and AOC
went to the schools in the ritzier
wealthier nicer area so you you assumed
she had a civics class she just didn't
learn very much from it and it's not
just AOC I don't just mean to pick on
AOC there is a congressman
representative Dan Goldman he has a much
more impressive prestigious academic
pedigree certainly than AOC does and he
was humiliated almost as much frankly
even perhaps more than AOC because the
expectations for this man were higher
when discussing a basic aspect of free
speech law with the legal scholar
Jonathan Turley
does the First Amendment protect someone
from yelling fire in a movie theater
well unfortunately that one is not yes
or no because that's become a mantra for
people it's the homes uh shank line
Holmes himself walk back on all right
homes and we don't need a law class here
um so but you do agree though don't you
that the First Amendment does not
protect all speech
no there are limits to speech all
constitutional rights have limits
I felt as though I were watching Always
Sunny in this exchange so he says at the
top can you yell fire in a crowded
theater to suggest that the right to
free speech is not absolute which is
true but the the of course it's not
absolute as Jonathan truly admits but
that phrase yelling fire in a credit
theater that comes from a very famous
case shank versus the United States it
was a case about whether or not a man
could be thrown in jail for passing out
flyers against the draft and against the
war and it's a complicated case I write
about it at length in my book speechless
controlling words controlling Minds
number one National bestseller on free
speech and the evolution of speech but
it's a complicated case and so Jonathan
Turley says well actually uh
representative Goldman you've picked
probably the worst example to talk about
this and because it's a little
complicated and it goes back to what
Oliver Wendell home said and what is the
representative goes hey hey hey all
right here listen we don't need to hear
about Liz we don't it was just the
Charlie Day response
everybody I know a lot about the law and
various other lawyerings I'm well
educated well-versed I know that
situations like this real estate wise
they're very complex actually they're
pretty simple the forms are all standard
boilerplate
okay well we're
let's talk about
it right I forgot where did you go to
law school again
uh well I could ask you that very soon I
went to Harvard how about you where yeah
I'm pleading the fifth sir I'd advise
that you do that and I'll take that
advice into cooperation all right now
let's say you and I go toe-to-toe and
bird law and see who comes out the
victim you know I don't think I'm gonna
do anything
um close to that and I can see clearly
you know nothing about the law it seems
like you have a tenuous grasp on the
English language in general okay well
filibuster
do you do you know what that word means
yeah yeah what's that mean
listen Professor can you do you do you
think you can yell fire in a crowded
theater
well actually
um the the case that used that example
ended up being largely overturned okay
okay listen here Mister we don't need
any of your lawyerings okay uh let's go
toe-to-toe on bird law that's what
representative Dan Goldman sounds like
and what's so embarrassing about this is
that the joke in Always Sunny is that
Charlie day is completely uneducated
representative Dan Goldman went to
Stanford law
Dan Goldman went to what is considered
the second best most prestigious Law
School in the country
and he he doesn't even understand the
context
of one of the most basic slogans from
one of the most basic cases of free
speech these people
don't know anything and it's not just
AOC it's very easy to make fun of AOC
because she's infamously ignorant
it's all these guys it's not just AOC
people make fun of where they say oh
she's a bartender I know plenty of
bartenders who are a lot smarter and
wiser than graduates of Stanford law
school okay what's the excuse of the
people from Stanford law school I don't
doesn't make you feel very confident
about the future of our political order
and our economy and our supply chain for
that matter which is why you got to
check out Jace medical right now go to
jacemedical.com promo code Knowles I'm
going to give you a scenario okay
imagine this it's not very difficult to
imagine China invades Taiwan
there goes your supply chain and America
is extraordinarily reliant on that
supply chain and on China it's not just
China there could be any major event
pops off in the world pandemic natural
disaster in that case even the basics
can be hard to come by you got to be
prepared for anything Chase medical is
here to help Jace medical helps you get
a long-term supply of prescription
medication their mission is to empower
you to be better medically prepared a
great way to start preparing is with the
Jace case a pack of five different
courses of antibiotics that you can use
to treat a whole host of bacterial
illnesses including UTIs respiratory
infections sinusitis skin infections and
more all you've got to do is fill out a
simple online form and in some cases
jump on a quick call with one of their
board certified Physicians from there
you can ask your physician treatment
related questions on an ongoing basis be
like the noses okay be prepared for
anything go to jacemedical.com enter
code Knowles kwels check out for a
discount on your order that's
jacemedical.com promo code nulls do it
today
the experts are not so expert
which brings me to a story a little bit
close to home
I was the subject of of a hit piece
yesterday that's right yours truly
your beloved podcast host
this is from The Brookings institution
probably the most prominent liberal
think think tank out there Brookings has
this very very lengthy report apparently
according to the author it took years to
put this report together and it opens
with with me and Ted Cruz it opens it's
called audible Reckoning how top
political podcasters spread
unsubstantiated and false claims in
February 2021 Texas Senator Ted Cruz and
his co-host Michael Knowles a daily wire
commentator recorded a live episode of
the verdict podcast in conversation
about his former Senate opponent Beto
O'Rourke Senator Cruz described his
rival support base as primarily
reporters who act like quote groupies at
a Rolling Stones concert throwing their
underwear offhandedly he added if they
were underwear with a smirk he leaned
into the mic and asked nulls too edgy
Knowles replied quote it's a podcast you
can say whatever you want
and then that's the intro
and they say yep that's it since the
Advent of the medium podcasts have
generally offered a space where in the
words of Knowles you can say wherever
you want and now all these people get
their news from podcasts and due in
large part to the say whatever you want
perceptions of the medium podcasting
offers a critical Avenue through which
unsubstantiated and false claims
proliferate there it is that Knowles
that Knowles she gave up the whole game
he admitted that that these podcasters
they just spread recklessly carelessly
spread lies and false claims
and although the author here tries to
make it sound like she's being really
balanced it becomes very clear very
quickly that she is accusing
conservatives of spreading much much
more false information than the Liberals
at one point I think she says that
conservatives spread something like 11
or that conservative spread something
like 11 times the false information that
liberals do and that because the
conservatives produce more podcasts than
the liberals do this is really really
dangerous
leads to lots of unsubstantiated and
false claims in podcasting okay
so I'm reading through this
friend of mine had texted it to me
earlier I'm reading through this
and I noticed something a little bit
weird I noticed there is a graph
in the pot and says top conservative
podcasts uh buy the number of podcasts
that have been produced and this is a
this is a print ready copy so it doesn't
have the graphics in here but
among the top political podcasts I'm
honored to say I was listed among them a
number of the daily water shows Ben
Shapiro Andrew Clavin Matt Walsh I'm
looking at all these shows and it was it
ranked us not by the ratings not by
daily downloads just by the number of
shows produced and it said X there are X
number of shows that have produced more
than a thousand episodes and I looked at
it and I said wait a second
Drew and Matt
are are both ranked higher than me in
terms of episodes produced but I know as
of today that isn't true
I have produced more episodes than they
have it's this is not a hard statistic
to look up you just go to the Daily wire
website or your podcast app you look
episode number X whatever and
I I've produced more episodes so I
looked and I said okay well
uh this seems like a really just a basic
statistic that was totally wrong the
reporter responded and said no no
Michael a you idiot I stopped collecting
data on January 22nd 2022 and so you you
just don't understand all my really
transparent and high-end methodologies I
said okay well just
I have I have always had produced more
episodes than Matt Walsh my show started
before Matt's show so that so I look
back at January 22nd 2022 and there it
is it's the data the the really basic
data in this long Brookings report that
allegedly took years and years to
produce about how the conservatives are
recklessly carelessly spreading false
information on the internet
the data on just one point just one that
I happened to see in a graph the basic
data are completely wrong which is
ironic I guess it's not ironic in that I
never expect these people to have their
data correct because I just don't
believe a word that they say and I don't
think they're particularly uh careful
and meticulous in what they do I think
they're just trying to smear
conservatives
and it turns out that was the case and
the author of the piece is so upset
about it she keeps trying to justify her
really really basic error the same kind
of basic error that AOC makes when she
gives a whole impassioned speech about
how Congress has no right to control DC
and then you say lady look at article
one of the Constitution it says Congress
has the right to control DC and to pass
the laws there it's really really basic
stuff
there's not much arguing with it January
1st 2022 the Michael Knowles show had
927 episodes out the Matt Walsh show had
878 episodes out take Drew out of it for
a second because his show had had
different it was daily at one point then
it turned to weekly but even just those
two the fact that you the fact that
this author at the Brookings Institution
could get just that really basic element
of data wrong
makes you realize oh I can't trust a
word in this report it drew actually
makes this point about the newspapers he
says
people are are very funny in that
they'll open the newspaper
and they'll read an article about Syria
they'll say well I don't know anything
about Sirius so I'll Trust what the
author has to say then they open and
they see a piece about the oil industry
they say I don't know anything about the
oil industry so I'll Trust what the
author has to say then they'll open it
to a piece about the New York Yankees
and they'll say I do know about the New
York Yankees they'll read the piece
they'll say oh the author's completely
wrong about the New York Yankees
then what happens
you turn the page
to an article about banana prices and
you say well I don't know about banana
prices I guess I'll believe the author
it's
if you can just if you can point out
you say wow I know for a fact the one
thing that I know about
in what these people are talking about I
know that that person is wrong
why would you believe anything else that
they have to say
now the ignorance I won't ascribe to
malice that which is explained by
incompetence and ignorance the ignorance
that you see in this kind of piece is
relatively trivial I know that it's
being used as a a justification to
censor all of our podcasts I guess mine
in particular but
there are more consequential uh sorts of
lies and deceit and
expressions of ignorance a clear one
would be the CDC telling you that the
fauci ouchies were completely effective
and completely safe
remember the CDC and
Dr fauci and Joe Biden said if you get
I'm just going to put them all together
in thatchy's voice if you get this yet
you won't get covered you won't transmit
covid and then that turned out not to be
true
people saying these Jets you have
nothing to worry about they're totally
tested very very very safe and then and
then it turns out actually some young
people are getting
awesome women are getting
there it would seem to be some
that comes along with these shots
sometimes and now we have
the CDC director of the immunization
Safety Office
just a couple of weeks ago
acknowledging
openly finally
the health problems that have been
attributed and associated with these
vaccines we take vaccine safety
um very seriously
uh with with respect to
um
reports of
people experiencing
um debilitating
illnesses
um I mean we we are we are aware of
these
um reports of people experiencing
long-lasting health problems
following covid vaccination
in some cases the clinical presentation
of people suffering these health
problems is variable
and no specific medical cause for the
symptoms have been found
we understand that illness is disruptive
and stressful especially under those
circumstances and we acknowledge these
health problems of substantially
impacted the quality of life for people
and have also affected those around them
and we hope
for improvement in recovery and we will
continue to monitor the safety of these
vaccines and and work with Partners to
try to better understand these types of
Adverse Events
now the fact Checkers out there are
already trying to push articles saying
that you did not hear what you just
heard
from the man who just said it
the man
who is Tom shimabukuro the CDC director
of the immunization Safety Office you
just heard what he said I'm not even
going to add commentary to what he said
lest the fact Checkers have any opening
to lie
I all I did all I just did was play his
words words that had you or I said those
words
and you or I said those words today we
would be called fact Checkers spreading
misinformation murderers probably kicked
off social media certainly had we said
those words two years ago
as they were rolling out those vaccines
oh my goodness you might have been
arrested you might you would have been
throwing Guantanamo Bay this is a danger
to the public health how dare you now
you're hearing that from the director of
the CDC immunization Safety Office
that's a pretty big error then it would
seem to hear that the vaccine's totally
effective totally safe
pretty that's a pretty big error pretty
consequential error
when you hear him talking about people
who are living with persistent health
problems
as a result of deceit as a result of
Lies as a result at the very least of
ignorance
don't do it don't allow yourself to be a
victim don't allow yourself to be a
victim of a bad economy diversify you
got to check out Birch gold right now
text Knowles kwles to 98 98 98 the U.S
blew through the 31.4 trillion dollar
debt ceiling last month and still the
White House refuses to reduce spending
if you're worried about the future of
this nation's economy you've got to
consider diversifying into gold with
Birch gold Birch gold makes it easy to
convert an IRA or 401K into an IRA in
Precious Metals text Knowles kwles to 98
98 98 to claim your free info kit on
gold and then talk to one of their
precious metals Specialists with an
A-Plus rating with the Better Business
Bureau thousands of happy customers and
countless five-star reviews you can
trust Birch gold to help protect your
savings right now text Knowles kwles to
98 9898 protect yourself with gold today
I have really enjoyed investing in
Precious Metals I am of Italian
extractions so you know we particularly
love gold there's a reason that
conservatives generally like to
diversify into gold text nulls kwles to
98 98 98 today
many prominent people who had previously
pushed the vaccine are now regretting it
one example would be Nancy mace I
mentioned her yesterday Nancy mace is a
liberal Republican who came out she said
I regretching the vaccine I feel I was
lied to I now have vaccine injuries that
I've got to deal with as a result of
this and I was impressed because Nancy
mace is a liberal Republican she's not a
Conservative Republican and she had
previously pushed the vaccine she had
peddled the vaccine on CNN
she was opposed to the mandates as far
as I can tell but she still encouraged
people to get it now she is regretting
it
I said okay at least good on Nancy mace
for admitting she was wrong but she
still continues to double down on her
opposition to the conservative
Republicans she still spends most of her
time attacking the more controversial
people in her own party and she spends a
lot of her time sucking up to the
Liberals she did this yesterday at the
the national Press Club Nancy mace was
invited to go there and tell some jokes
it was supposed to be a roast kind of
funny telling jokes at the Press Club
here's the performance
I know George Santos hoped to deliver
tonight's keynote but organizers our
lovely beautiful organizers one is
someone who could tell a joke but not
actually be one
come on George you've given Republicans
a bad name and that's Lauren bobert's
job
Lauren don't shoot
I mean really like who lies about being
about playing college volleyball like
who does that
foreign
like you actually won the 2020
presidential election
I was one of the first Republicans I
know there's some New Yorkers in here
too Republicans who asked uh who said
Santos should resign
s should step down to show people you
can't lie cheat and steal to win
election unless of course if you're
Donald Trump or Joe Biden
I said this so this can air on Fox News
and CNN
I go both ways I mean come on
you got it you got it
it's like watching a bad imitation of
Mean Girls
Republican Congress lady Nancy mace she
was she says hey
I'm not a regular Republican I'm a cool
Republican hey hey press
come on it's I'm not like those bad
Republicans oh cool I'm a cool mom yeah
okay right
are you are you that's never cool
unfortunately
even the making fun of George Santos
that's that's fine and it's funny I've
made plenty of jokes about George Santos
but it's it's sort of depends on the
spirit in which one makes the joke and
the type of person who makes the joke
in that
I can make fun of my brother you can't
make fun of my brother
if I make fun of my bra I don't even
have a brother I have a stepbrother if I
make fun of my stepbrother that's fine
that's okay but if you make fun of my
step brother that's offensive
so the question is what is the
perspective Nancy mace is coming from
Nancy mace is coming from the
perspective of a liberal Republican who
at every chance she gets attacks
conservative Republicans and and tries
to Curry favor with the Liberals
you could say well this was a roast
people are telling jokes that's fine get
a sense of humor yo I'm all for that I
think I think that's a great idea but
Nancy mace never once told any
self-effacing joke she never made a joke
about her own side
because her her side is not Republican
she opposes conservative Republicans her
side or the liberal squishy Republicans
and she didn't make any jokes about them
that's that's really pathetic and I play
that to remind you there are still a
number of those types out there we think
that the conservative party you know the
Republican party now is being run by the
conservatives not by the squishes not by
the moderates not but there are still a
lot of centrists out there uh governor
of New Hampshire Chris sununu is
floating the idea of a presidential
campaign I know it's very silly most
people have never even heard of Chris
sununu it's probably not going to happen
but he certainly wants to run for
president in 2024. and the way that he
is positioning himself is
specifically as a Centrist
a lot of the folks that you mentioned
and a lot of folks that we all know who
are likely to run for president on the
Republican side are more conservative
your house are moderate well president
I'm the most I'm ranked the most
fiscally conservative government of the
country I'm number one in personal
freedoms right I'm sorry Ron you're
number two
sorry Florida
um I would challenge anyone on Second
Amendment rights we're Far and Away the
best you know because we believe in
those individual freedoms uh regulatory
reform I'll challenge any state on it so
in my more social more moderate on the
social issues yeah maybe but that's not
what I got on this game for management
I'm a manager I'm a CEO I like to manage
and redesign systems but I would tell
you on those social issues we get better
results than almost anywhere else
there it is got to give the guy credit
for honesty he says I want to be a
manager Mike Bloomberg this was his
pitch to run for president in 2020 as a
Democrat he said look I'm a manager I
just want to manage things
that is
the exact opposite of what we need in
this country
I do not want to manage
the decline
I think our country is in Decline I
don't want to just manage the decline I
don't want my president my Republican
conservative president to manage the
decline
I want him to fix things
you might not think that well you
probably do think the country's in
Decline but some liberals out there they
might say no the country's not in
Decline even if it's not in Decline I
don't want you just to manage the
liberal establishment I want a
conservative to go in there and advocate
for good things and pursue good things
and oppose evil things
pursue truth and avoid falsehood pursue
Beauty and avoid ugliness that's what I
want he says look I'm very conservative
I mean maybe not on those cultural
issues
but what is that even what I don't even
know what that means
it
it's like saying I love coffee I hate
caffeine
you're you're pretending that you
support a thing but then you you oppose
the essence of that thing
oh yeah I'm just not conservative on the
cultural issues
that well that's the whole story okay
you can cut taxes I'm very conservative
I can conserve
tax cuts maybe yeah I'm even questioning
whether that certain conservatives can
do that no no managers no managers no
squishes
there is too much at stake our
government is being run by people who
don't know the first thing about the
Constitution or a political order or the
law or anything and it's not just the
infamously ignorant people it's even the
ones with the fancy degrees from the
fancy law schools that the fancy think
tanks they don't know anything they are
so ignorant our genius experts whose job
it is to be genius expert nerds get the
most basic aspects of their jobs wrong
and make us all take experimental drugs
that often don't turn every well that
we're in a really tough spot
I do not want someone to just manage the
status quo the status quo is is very
sick and we need we need to fix it
Governor sununu you're not going to
you're not going to be the president
you're certainly not gonna get my vote
if you want to manage this desiccated
degraded status quo to celebrate
President's Day this year daily wire is
launching our presidents for sale sale
with 40 off new annual memberships the
big guy got 10 we're giving you 40
percent get access to the world of daily
wire plus with Fearless documentaries
gripping movies Dennis breaker's
master's program
the entire library of Dr Jordan
Peterson's work including new
productions Exodus logos and literacy on
marriage all available to watch right
now coming down the pipeline to a TV or
a laptop near you
new episodes of Ben Shapiro's the search
Exodus part two are much anticipated DW
kids content and Pendragon later this
year to sweeten the deal we are also
giving you up to 40 off select items in
the daily wire shop take advantage of
our president's for sale sale today you
know that he would just go to
dailywire.com subscribe to become a
member today that's dailywire.com
subscribe we're going to be getting to
the member block uh obviously after the
mailbag but just want to let everyone
know a lot of people are talking about
how uh James O'Keefe appears to be out
at project Veritas there seems to be a
coup taking place within project Veritas
to put James O'Keefe who to my mind is
Project Veritas I think the two are
synonymous they're going to put him on
leave I guess right after this amazing
expose on Pfizer he's getting a lot of
heat for that so anyway we have a a
former a project Veritas undercover
journalist who is going to give us the
behind the scenes scoop because James
has not been making public statement
about it so we'll get we'll get the
inside story that will be on the member
block
first though the mailbag sponsored by
Pure Talk go to puretalk.com select a
plan enter code Knowles Canada wlas get
50 off your first month let's take it
away with the first question
hey Michael I'm Kate a happy little
introvert who works from home and as
such I look forward to watching your
show every morning so thank you for
everything that you do I have two
questions for you today
for some context when my husband and I
first met it was deemed improbable at
best and dangerous at worst to pursue
having children therefore my husband
married me knowing that our family would
grow and evolve into something a bit
different through the years we've
developed a huge passion not for kids
but for young adults specifically in
that 18 to 25 year Peter Pan phase of
destructively extended adolescence right
now we have a 19 year old living with us
he is the eighth young adult to spend a
transitionary and equipping season in
our home many of whom who have never
learned how to perform basic functions
or had ever witnessed healthy dialogue
in familial relationships now that the
doctors say I could start trying for
children we found that this would create
a conflict with our desire to Foster
these young adults into true adulthood
for how could we responsibly house
potentially Wayward men in a home with
little vulnerable children so my first
question is this given that you believe
believe having children is a command
from God do you allow for the notion for
his church to Target and meet a
multitude of needs in a broken world
this might have to take on different
forms because in many ways my husband
and I do have children many in fact they
are just big lovable Knuckleheads
traipsing in and out of our home at any
given time
here's my second question and one you
might enjoy in that same vein we are
involved in a couple different
organizations hosting events all the
time from Deep theological study nights
to informal Community Fellowship every
weekend we now have roughly 12 to 30
young adults at the house often staying
close to midnight discussing topics of
all kinds so if given the same
opportunity what would you want to
impress most upon the Elder gen's ears
thank you so much can't wait to hear
your answer bye that's a lot I'll try to
keep it pithy what you're doing for
those young men is
unbelievably charitable I'm not sure
that I could Muster that I I barely like
talking to the 19 year old men that I'm
related to or relatives of my friends
that that's a tough period that those
young so to invite them into your home
that is incredibly charitable and you're
right if you have young children you
can't just invite these
this strange men of fighting age into
your home that would be irresponsible I
don't know your specific medical
situation or what the doctors have said
if the doctors previously said you'll
die if you have kids that that raises uh
certainly uh all sorts of dilemmas for
you and if the doctors are now saying
you can have kids no big deal go ahead
and have children then I would do that
you've done your good charitable work
having children is a wonderful thing and
you're called to do it you were called
to do it within the context of marriage
so you're married you can have kids do
it I've got two kids I want to have a
hundred more kids I think it's it's a
great thing so go for it that's what
that was what I would recommend and if
it doesn't work out plenty of couples
struggle with infertility who knows no
one has the right to a baby if it
doesn't work out you can go right back
to the charitable work you're doing and
that sounds great as for the the
youth groups that are coming through
your home hanging out until until
midnight what would you want to talk
about
I would flip it I
I would allow them to propose the topics
of discussion and the reason for this is
an important part of education is desire
and and we often don't think about this
when we talk about education because we
think of Education as sit down do it do
what you're told copy the things that we
want you to copy
and learn the fact that we want you to
learn and then go out and and go to the
next grade but
key part of education is desire
a soul that does not wish to be educated
cannot cannot really be educated this is
the point that Plato makes in book seven
of the Republic
so so see what they bring up
and then whatever they do bring up you
should pursue that train of thought
all the way through its various levels
through its literal meaning through its
allegorical meanings
political implications cultural
implications and then ultimately up to
the highest level of knowledge which
would be Theology and then you could go
down a really great journey uh but I I
would allow the the desire of the people
in the conversation to guide that and I
wouldn't make an organized lesson plan
okay next question
hey Michael I have a couple of friends
who are agnostic and or atheists I want
to show them the truth of the Bible and
I believe the events of the Bible are
true but I feel like if I were to cite
the Bible to prove my point it would be
like an evolutionist pointing to
different parts of a textbook and
claiming fact we wouldn't have an agreed
upon a piece of evidence that we could
further debate I'm really curious to
know if I should use the Bible to prove
itself and if so what passages should I
cite or use another book or historical
record that proves Christianity or at
least makes it more believable thanks
well the Bible is inerrant and it is uh
the word of God
in a textual sense
Christ himself is the word of God the
Divine logic of the universe in that
larger sense but the the scripture is a
great place to convince people and
persuade people because you're you're
using the the very words of God uh but I
I think you're starting a little down
the line here
and and this is a common
mistake I think in our Modern Age
especially in age that has divorced the
Bible from all sense of
uh history and Authority but the Bible
didn't just drop out of the sky don't
forget the Bible was compiled the Bible
was compiled and agreed upon in a Canon
by an ecumenical council of the church
so the church predates the Bible and
what is the church the church is the
body of Christ instituted by Christ here
on Earth and who is Christ Christ is the
Incarnate second person of the Trinity
and what is the Trinity who is the
Trinity the Trinity is God three persons
in one Divine unity and who is God and
does God really exist I think you've
probably got to start there and the
existence of God can be known with
certainty by the light of of human
reason
within the context of the natural world
you don't need the Bible to prove that
God exists
the Bible
illuminates
aspects of God
but but it is not a requirement to to
know that God exists so I would probably
start there
that's where you would have to start if
you were proposing a science textbook
let's say that you wanted to persuade
your friend of something Charles Darwin
said not not that I'm encouraging that
necessarily
but you wouldn't just begin with from
the Origin of Species you would begin
with who is Charles Darwin
What observations did he make what
experiments did he under undertake
what was the historical context in which
Charles Darwin came about what was he
reacting against that that's probably
what you would do
if you were to show a science work on
say the big bang you would say who is
George lametra and you would find out
that George lamentra is actually a
Catholic priest the man who discovered
the big bang and the term was actually a
term of derision by atheists who wanted
to make fun of the idea that this priest
had had discovered something about the
origin of the universe that seemed to
Accord perfectly with the Genesis
account so anyway that's that's where
you would begin I would I would begin
there does God exist if God exists
who is God what is God like uh what what
does the the Incarnation mean in in the
light of
who God is
and
then what do we know about the
Incarnation and and at that point I
think you you get to the Bible next
question
hi Michael I am wondering why you prefer
the Latin Mass over the English mass but
criticize the Spanish response to the
State of the Union
as you've said once or twice culture is
Downstream of politics and our Catholic
identity is part of our culture so I'm
curious to see what you think about this
I thought this question would be extra
relevant this week because in case you
haven't heard there is a football team
representing the Cradle of Liberty
playing in a big game this weekend that
you may want to catch go Eagles have a
nice weekend Michael
I actually hadn't heard that like I knew
the Super Bowl was happening but I am so
tuned out of football especially since
all the BLM stuff that I I didn't even
know that the Eagles were playing but
that's cool all right that's that's good
good on the Eagles as for the the
question of the Spanish state of the
union versus the Latin Mass one if the
State of the Union response were in
Latin that'd be a completely different
story because at least then you're
speaking the language that once United
all of Western Christendom but
we don't have that anymore we don't have
a unified Christian Empire or anything
even resembling that
we have Nations and here we have The
American Nation and the purpose of the
State of the Union is to describe the
state of our nation one nation under God
indivisible a Pluribus Unum out of many
one and so it is contrary to the very
idea of the State of the Union Address
to give it in multiple languages
because those multiple languages suggest
a division and specifically
the insertion of Spanish into the state
of the union is an acknowledgment of
mass migration and the failure of
assimilation specifically from a handful
of Latin American countries and and so
the medium can become the message A lot
of people are saying well why can't we
just get the conservative message out to
Spanish people I think that's a great
idea I have nothing against Hispanic
people I have nothing against the
Spanish language I speak
romance languages I look fairly Hispanic
myself so I've got nothing against any
of that but I'm I'm recognizing here
that if you give a deeply conservative
message
in a medium that is not very
conservative that is radical that that
goes along with the premises of the
Liberals then you're not really
presenting a conservative message at all
that's a bad idea the question is what
is it for I find Latin is better suited
to the mass well one the traditional
Latin mass is a little bit confusing
because it's it's not just about the
language it's a it's it's a different
Mass the Liturgy is different the
orientation of it is different I find it
to be much more reverent it's obviously
much more traditional and I think it's
more more conducive to worship
but
the Latin the language is also better
suited for the mass because it shows a a
Unity a universality a catholicity it's
Catholic in the sense that until the
last 50 years or so
you could go anywhere on Earth you could
walk into the mass they would be
speaking the same language
it shows you something about the
universal church
if you if you look at the State of the
Union the purpose of it is to express
the state of our American Nation and so
it should be conducted in the language
of the American nation which is English
next question
hi Michael you were talking I think it
was yesterday or the day before about
embryos and having them Frozen and how
that was wrong so I have an older sister
and she had some infertility issues and
her and her husband just were not able
to get pregnant but thankfully through
IVF they've been able to get pregnant
and they have several embryos Frozen for
their future plans for future family and
anyway I was asking her what they're
gonna do because they have more than
they want
children wise and anyway I was curious
what your thoughts were on what to do
with those frozen embryos I know you
don't like the embryos but I just the
fact of you have them and I was just
curious what your thoughts were on
what you would do in that situation my
husband and I just we could not figure
out what to do and yeah do you destroy
these people these babies or do you let
someone else have your essentially your
child and have that child never know you
and yeah I just thought that was a very
thought-provoking question that I knew
you would have a very good answer for so
anyway love the show thanks thank you
very much I hope I have a good answer
for it uh just once like correction
there you said Michael I know you don't
like the embryos I like the embryos very
much in fact that is why I don't support
these forms of artificial contraception
the question you bring up of embryo
adoption is is a difficult one and I
think remains an open one it is such a
modern phenomenon it's such a recent
phenomenon that bioethicists are still
debating this at their the church has
not uh rendered any judgment one way or
the other uh
it would
it is tempting to say well people should
just adopt these memories I don't think
we should destroy them I think that
would be wrong
but we we also need to recognize that
procreation is to take place in the
context of a marriage uh within the
conjugal Union of husband and wife and
and children have a right to their
natural mother and father bound together
in marriage which is for the good of the
spouses and the sake of the generation
and education of children so
there is a temptation to say okay well
we are where we are this is a bad
scenario so we're not going to kill the
embryos but we maybe we'll take them and
implant them in other people
I don't I don't know that that's quite
the right idea
that it
exacerbates another problem which is the
establishment of the domination of
Technology over the origin and Destiny
of human life that is not acceptable at
all it separates procreation from the
conjugal act that is not acceptable
so what does one do I think what one
does is not rush to judgment there's
there's a an Impulse in especially in
the modern world to the moment that some
new technology comes out and becomes
popular we we have to render a for all
an eternity sort of uh bioethical
judgment on it and this can lead to
really bad consequences I think of
Lambeth you know the the notion where
Protestant churches came out and
endorsed aspects of the sexual
Revolution endorsed artificial
contraception and the like that I think
a lot of that came out of a sense of
urgency
along with other mistakes but but it led
to so many more problems down the road
whereas what I would do in this case is
I would allow the bioethicists the real
bioethicists you know the people who
were trained in this regard to to debate
this for some period of time and what I
would do in the meantime is proceed with
caution
and uh and and follow the first advice
of the Hippocratic Oath first Do no harm
all right we've got uh we've got the
real scoop on Project Veritas coming up
we've also got a Super Bowl watch party
this weekend Crane and Company will be
hosting a live Super Bowl watch party
this Sunday for Super Bowl 57 who's
playing I don't know but join the live
apparently the Eagles right that's what
the guy just said so join the live
stream at 6 PM Eastern 5 p.m Central on
YouTube and daily wire plus here we go
we've got Cassandra Spencer former
project fairy task employee and uh
whistleblower over there at Facebook the
rest of the show continues now you don't
want to miss it become a member use code
Knowles at dailywire.com Knowles for two
months free on all annual plans we will
see you with the scoop
on Project Veritas
[Music]